hello and welcome to kaijan's webinar
thank you for joining us today
my name is laura and i'm your host for
today's webinar
on kaikuite digital pcr applications
detection of
mutations before we start let me quickly
introduce you to our speaker today
earthen caroline studied molecular
biology and genetics at the middle east
technical university in turkey and
obtained her master of science degree in
neuroscience from the mpi for
developmental biology
in two minutes she received her
doctorate in neuroscience from the swiss
federal institute of technology and
zurich
and she joined kyogen after completion
of her post-doctoral research at the mpi
for biology of aging in cologne
and since then she has been involved in
yeah developing the digital pcr
essay portfolio including mutation
detection
and cnv essays i'm very happy to have
her here today
and with that i would like to hand over
to islam to start her presentation
thanks um thank you very much laura for
this uh nice introduction
i would also like to welcome our
audience
thank you all for your interest in our
digital pcr webinars
it's my pleasure today to introduce you
to our kai acuity digital pcr platform
and more specifically today i will be
talking about
its application for detection of rare
mutations
first of all i will give you a brief
introduction and talk about
limitations of mutation detection and
how
the digital pcr technology overcomes
these limitations
i will then mostly focus on showing you
various examples
uh for quantitation of rare mutations in
wide variety of sample types
so before i start just a brief
disclaimer
i would like to remind you that the
products that i mentioned in my
presentation
are not intended for diagnosis
prevention
or treatment of diseases
okay without further delay mutations can
be caused by various agents
they can be caused by intrinsic cellular
changes for example
failure of cellular mechanisms such as
dna replication mistakes
or they can be induced by external
factors such as exposure to chemicals or
radiation there are different type of
mutations
deletions substitutions inversions
insertions
and they can lead to permanent changes
in the
genome sequence and they can range from
a single base pair
all the way up to the whole segments in
chromosomes
they can be inherited and they can be
passed on
so depending on their frequency in the
genome they can be frequently observed
or
very rarely observed but irrespective of
their frequency within the genome
mutations are widespread throughout the
whole human genome
some mutations lead to beneficial
effects for example some mutations
account for
polymorphisms such as hair and eye color
or blood type so they cause um natural
genetic variation in humans
on the other hand some mutations have
very severe phenotypes and are linked to
common and complex diseases
here on the left side you see a list of
common diseases in humans
what you see here is some of these
diseases are caused by
single mutation events such as point
mutations or deletions
and they have very varying prevalence in
humans
in fact more than 10 000 human diseases
are
known or predicted to be caused by
single gene mutations
what you also see here is that some of
these diseases are caused by
multiple complex mutation events also
even on different chromosomes
a very good example for this is breast
cancer
so here on the right side you see the
two mutations
vertical one and two that lead to
progression of breast cancer so these
two mutations are located on different
chromosomes chromosome 13 and chromosome
17.
and each of these chromosomes themselves
have
different mutations that lead to
different diseases
so in fact um mutations in more than
4000 genes are
identified in the human genome that lead
to single gene disorders or that lead to
complex diseases
such as cancer
there are two major drivers of cancer
tumor development mutations that lead to
activation of oncogenes
um such as birov keras or mec
and mutations that lead to loss of
function in tumor suppressors
such as p time or more famous the p53
they all lead to tumor progression
multiple oncogenes and multiple tumor
suppressors
are known to be altered across multiple
cancer types
for example mutations in oncogenes egfr
and
rbb2 as well as mutations in
p53 tumor suppressor p53
both lead to ovarian and breast cancers
so although we know a lot about the
cancer related genes and mutations
there are still various limitations for
profiling of these
mutations in especially patient samples
so what are these limitations um
identification of novel mutations in
patient samples
as well as identification of residual
mutations with very low frequencies in
samples are
a few of these limitations
some of these limitations some of these
challenges are
caused by the quality and quantity of
patient samples
there are various sources for patient
samples
tissue biopsies such as fresh or frozen
biopsies cell lines obtained from
patients
or liquid biopsies can be used
to analyze mutations
each of these different type of samples
have different amounts of dna
they also have different amounts of for
example contaminants
which might later on affect the quality
of dna extraction
and each of these sample types also have
different sample homogeneities
depending on their source patient
samples can have different
heterogeneity they can contain multiple
tumors
and each of these tumors can contain
different type of tissues and different
type of mutations
so with the increase in heterogeneity of
the samples
the frequency of an individual mutation
within the sample decreases
making it difficult for its
identification
in such cases higher sensitivity and
resolution of detection is needed
digital pcr platform provides an
unmatched sensitivity and precision
for detection of such low frequency
mutations especially in comparison to
prior technologies such as quantitative
pcr
digital pcr provides a platform
for high throughput profiling of
mutations
in addition combined with the
ngs results digital pci can be used for
validation of new mutations
or for validation of residual mutations
here on the right side you see the two
hallmarks of digital pcr technology
random distribution of dna samples or
dna molecules into partitions
and the absolute quantification of the
dna molecules
based on statistical poisson
distribution model
so the end result the end read-off of a
digital pcr run
is the absolute copies of wild-type and
mutated sequences within samples
but what is the advantage of
partitioning
so partitioning of dna molecules or dna
samples
increases their effective concentration
imagine there are two targets of
interest in a 16 microliter
sample volume so here the concentration
is one molecule in eight microliter
one in eight if we allocate this or
if we divide this sample into 16 equal
partitions
each of partition will be one microliter
and according to random distribution um
according to the random distribution of
dna molecules
each of these two target molecules will
go into separate partitions thus
we will have one molecule of target in
one microliter of sample
which leads to the eight volts increase
in its effective concentration
imagine a second scenario where we are
looking at two target molecules
for example two mutated sequences
which are diluted among uh
among a background of wild-type
molecules so here again we assume we
have
a concentration of one in eight
if we divide this sample again into 16
partitions
what we will have is that some of these
mutated sequences will be sharing
a partition with some other y-type
molecules
here for example in this case we will
have one mutated sequence and while
one y-type sequence in the same
partition
and its effective concentration would be
one in one microliter so it will lead to
again
eight false purification in some other
cases however
one of these target molecules will be
alone in the partition
which leads to complete purification of
this
[Music]
of this target molecule thus
by partitioning the target molecule
or thus by partitioning the samples
uh we will be increasing their effective
concentration
and decreasing also the effect of
interfering molecules
this will allow us to detect much lower
mutation frequencies with
increased sensitivity and accuracy
kaiogen offers a digital pcr platform
which is optimum for detection of
rare mutations depending on the sample
availability
input volume as well as the desired
sensitivity of mutation detection
24 well plates with 26 000 partitions
or 96 valve plates with more than 8 000
partitions can be used
prop pcr reagents are optimized for
use with mutation essays and provide
the best performance in nanoplate
microfluidic environment
depending on the number of samples to be
analyzed
users can select from either 1
four or eight plate instruments allowing
for high
throughput screening of mutations in
large number of samples
results from a digital pcr run can
easily
be analyzed using acuity software suite
which provides an accurate and detailed
analysis of mutations in samples
and important consideration for mutation
analysis is actually not just
the platform use but also the essays
kai acuity mutation assays are lna
enhanced primers and props
which provide higher sensitivity and
highest discrimination power between
wild-type and mutated sequences
two mutations can be detected
simultaneously using four fluorophore
combinations
farm and hex folder force for the first
mutation
opto550 and rox fluorophores for the
second mutation
lna mutation assays are wet lab
validated assays
with sensitivity as low as 0.1 percent
mutation frequencies
so uh from now on i will be showing you
data
obtained using uh acute lna mutation
essays
so here you see a list of mutations and
these mutations are
hot spots and they occur quite
frequently in multiple tensor types
such as egfr keras and b rav
so we generated synthetic templates with
varying degrees of mutation frequencies
all the way from 100 percent all the way
down to 0.1 percent mutation frequencies
and as you can see from our results lna
mutation assays and various essays are
listed here
are accurately identifying the mutation
frequencies in each of these samples
next i would like to show you some
results that we obtained using
ffp samples um
formally fixed paraffin embedded samples
so we used horizon standard templates
which have varying degrees of
fragmentation mild medium and severe
and we checked these templates for vraf
v600e mutation and this mutation
is expected to be a present at 11
frequency in these samples as you can
see
from the results uh right bottom corner
independent of the template
concentration
whether we put 30 nanogram or 3 nanogram
inside a single reaction
we were able to identify
the frequency of p rough mutation in
these sample samples
as you can see at the bottom of the
results
we were able to detect 10.7 percent
mutation frequency even in severely
fragmented
ffpe samples
however here i would like to pause and
remind you that there are several
challenges associated with using fspe
samples
formula fixation is known to lead
crosslinking
degradation or deamination of dna
sequences
and as well as fragmentation
it leads to basically destruction of
amplicon sequences that we would like to
target and this all together can lead to
inaccurate quantification of mutation
frequencies
so what i'm showing you here is actually
the same templates that we use but this
time we
checked another mutation we used an lna
mutation essays that
target egfr deletion
mutation and what you can see on the
right bottom side is actually
depending on the increase in
fragmentation
the mutation frequencies that we
observed
increased leading to inaccurate
quantification of mutation frequencies
so there are different ways to overcome
this
control templates can be used that are
also
equally fragmented or users can also
always target another essays that are
known to be present at a certain
mutation
frequency in the same samples
um so i will be also showing you some
results from patient samples
um as i already mentioned you at the
beginning of my talk
one of the biggest challenges in
detection of mutations in
patient samples is f in fact the
quantity of dna in these samples
is most of the time the limiting
factor so what we have here is
uh we have ffp samples obtained from
colorectal cancer patients and we tested
these um
samples again for the b rough mutation
itself
and what we did was we loaded two
microliter of these patient samples
directly into a single well of
26k nanoplate as you can see
we were able to detect as long as 0.5
and 0.8 copies
of mutated b rough sequences in
in a microliter of these patient samples
overall we were able to detect 3.8
and 6.3 percent period of mutations in
these two patient samples
and on the upper panel you again see the
exact same data
and at the bottom what i'm showing you
is actually our control
samples as i mentioned it's always a
good idea to include
control samples especially when using
ffp samples
and um what you see here at the bottom
is that we generated
some synthetic mixture of templates
and um we detected the beer of uh
v600e mutation that we use the exact
same essays
and you can see that we can detect as
low as 0.1 percent mutation frequencies
in these samples
another point of consideration is the
specificity of
mutation detection essays and
[Music]
here i will be showing you results from
two different cell lines mcf7 and skbr
3 cell lines these are widely studied
breast cancer cell lines and
as you know almost 50 percent of all
breast cancer harbor
pik3ca mutations
and we tested these two cell lines for
pik3ca mutations
and what we obtained was that
sorry and we actually picked pik3ca
mutations that
are only a single base pair
different we looked at e545k
g and a mutations in these two cell
lines
and as you can see from our results we
detected around 53 percent
e 545 k mutation in mcf7 cell lines
but we did not detect all the other
mutations
and and this is also um
uh known in the literature and in skbr
three cell lines we did not
detect any of these mutations so lna
mutation assays
are actually able to discriminate a
single base payer difference in the
target sequences
so we use the same exact pik3ca
mutation essays that i showed in the
slide before
and this time we tested a patient sample
ffpa breast tumor tissue
and in this in the sample we detected
e545a mutation
at a rate of 16.9 percent frequency
and we also looked at all the other
mutations
and we detected them only some of them
at a very residual rate
so for example we detected along with
the
e545a mutation we were able to take
0.6 percent c
420 r mutation
and again uh i would like to show you
that
you can also use our kai acuity lna
mutation essays
on different variety of templates
here i'm showing you two different
sample types
one sample is obtained from ffpe breast
tumor tissue
and the other one is obtained from the
plasma
and we checked again
these two different type of samples for
the pik3ca mutation
and we were able to detect around 15 and
16 percent mutations of this
of this gene in the two samples
and on the right side again you see
our control group our control samples
where we generated synthetic samples
with 0.5 percent and 0.1
uh mutation frequencies for this
particular
mutation and again the same essays can
detect
as low as 0.1 percent mutation
frequencies
the last but not the least i would like
to also present you the multiplexing
capacity of our platform
so far i only showed you the data that
was obtained by using two floor force
and
farm floor four for detecting the
mutated sequences
and hex fluorophore for detecting uh the
wild type sequences in green and yellow
channels
and here again um on the left side you
see a typical
ex result that i also showed you before
we were able to detect in these
synthetic samples around 8.44
mutation frequency for egfr t790n
mutation
so not just duplexing but the digital
pcr
platform allows for multiplexing up to
five full force
so if you would like to detect two
mutations simultaneously
we can use four floor fours in
combination
for the first mutation we can use thumb
and hex
fluorophore combinations and for the
second mutation we can use
ato 550 and rox fluorophore combinations
and use green yellow orange and red
channels
so here on the right side you see the
results that we obtained
when we sparked in a second
sample with the second notation
so uh as you can see
uh in addition to egfr t790m mutation we
also spiked in
a sample that carries a five percent
uh uh it carries a beer of
v600e mutation at a frequency of five
percent
and what we were able to accurately
identify
was using the form and hex combination
the very first mutation
egfr mutation at a rate of 8.46 percent
and the second mutation the p rough
mutation we were also able to detect
at a highly accurate level at 4.44
percent
so by using by combining four
fluorophores
we will still accurately identify two
mutations simultaneously
and um this brings me almost to the end
of my presentation
but i would like to encourage you to go
and check our essays in gene globe
um lna mutation essays are all wetland
validated essays and they
cover highly studied cancer mutations
and we will be increasing our product
portfolio over time
so this brings me to the end of my
presentation
what i told you so far is that i
gave you a brief introduction about
mutations and limitations of mutation
detection
and how digital pcr platform in fact
overcomes uh some of these limitations
and high acuity digital pcr
platform provides a highly sensitive
and accurate quantification of mutations
even in limited amount of samples
and our lna mutation assays can detect
as low as 0.1 percent mutation
frequencies in single wells
and in variety of samples including for
example ffpe samples
a large digital pcr lna mutation sa
portfolio
allows extensive study of individual
cancer genes and also related
pathways and related genes and i would
also like to
mention here that lna mutation essays
are optimized
uh using high acuity probe pcr kit
and optimized for use in combination
with kayaking
digital pcr instrument
so this brings me to the end of my
presentation
i thank you for your attention and
i would be happy to answer your
questions
thank you islam thank you for the very
nice detailed um
information we indeed already
got some questions during your
presentation and
yeah i would say i'm going to start
um yeah reading them one by one
and you can focus then on answering them
so the first questions or the first
question we received
was about
that someone uses digital pcr
and that the main challenge is obtaining
enough dna concentration from plasma
what do you mean concentration wise
that you use two microliter of patient
sample and nanogram
your system detected mutation in dna
samples with concentrations below five
nanograms so basically what is the total
input so um
of course in combination with lna
mutation assays and in general
the capacity of our high acuity platform
we can go as low as 10 to 20 nanograms
per reaction volume uh for example for
26k
this would be actually um
as low as 10 to 20 nanograms in 40
microliters
okay should i go to this
yeah i will go to the next one um
what is the maximum input i'm not sure
if you have
uh answered that already but yeah i will
i would just
read it what is the maximum input in
nanogram per well
and what is the maximum resolution per
well
percentage mutant to wiretite or
fractional abundance
i'm not so sure if i understand can you
please repeat laura
what is the maximum input in nanogram
per well
maybe we start with that so
the optimum range or the maximum amount
of dna that can be added into a single
reaction
uh would be 450 nanograms for optimal
um readout so between
0.5 and 3 copies per partition is
would be the optimum range of detection
and is that coming also along with the
maximum resolution per well that was the
second part of the question
resolution very well um in
general uh we can detect as low as um
[Music]
in terms of nanograms or
yeah i think that will answer it um
because i don't have also any
any more information here to the
questions
another one do i need a different master
mix for doing
single plex mutation duplex or mutation
fourplex
experiments no um the same master mix
can be used for single plex and
multiplexing experiments
okay um and then there was also another
question
um how much sample can i load to my
digital pcr mutation reaction
that's the first one and then to load as
much as possible to find my rare
target
um up to 27 microliters can be loaded
actually in
uh 26 000 k
plates number plates
um until which mutation mutat sorry
mutation
frequency the 8.5 k
nanoplate might be usable regarding
sensitivity
when using 8.5 k
nano plates 96 well plates i would
recommend
[Music]
going as low as 5 mutation frequencies
and there was also another question
regarding nanoplates
will you design a 26k nanoplate in a 96
well format
this is a really good question because
this is
what i was also talking about in my
presentation
sometimes we receive patient samples and
these samples are
limited in amounts or we don't know the
concentration of
dna in these samples and it would be
wise to load as much as possible
and in these cases basically we can
go for the maximum amount of volume that
we can use for
the samples and use this um these
plates okay
um going through the next one how many
mutations
can you detect in one reaction
um two mutations can be detected
simultaneously although
our platform allows for up to five
fluorophores
we have been developing
essays that can detect
two mutations at the same time using
four
fluorophore combinations farm and hex
and ato 550 and rocks would be the
second
mutation
thank you um
is the platform open to other essays
non-cajon or non-lna
would the results be as good
um of course we did intensive testing
of course we can use all different type
of essays in our platform but
our mutation essays are specifically
developed and optimized for our platform
so it would be wiser to use lna mutation
essays in combination with kai acuity
digital pcr platform
um i think we also have received a lot
of questions
which are not in english i'm sorry i i
cannot um
i cannot understand them and i cannot
ask them but
um i saw also a lot of questions
regarding um
if uh yeah our audience here are getting
the
um presentation yes you will get the
presentation you will also get
the recording afterwards um
here was another one do you have
any ce ivd essays
that is probably also a good one to ask
you
islam um
can you repeat please do you have any ce
ivd
essays um no not yet but uh we will be
working on those
also soon
and then what different instruments
comprise the kai acuity systems
sorry the kai acuity system
um i don't understand this question
sorry
can you repeat what different
instruments
comprise the kayakurity system
i would understand yeah so we had three
different
type of instruments with the one plate
um
four plate and eight plates i think um
i understand that this is the question
so we have three different type of
instruments
and depending on the number of samples
depending on the power of a
high throughput analysis that the users
need they can
go for instruments with
higher capacity and four plates
i would like to thank you all for your
attention for all your questions this
session thank you all thank you aslam
for you as a speaker here
and with that i wish you um yeah a happy
rest of the day thank you all